foreign
[Music]
this is footage from the operation IV
nuclear test in 1952.
and this is a clip from the movie them a
film released just two years later about
giant irradiated ants and it wasn't the
only film from the atomic age about
mutant animals terrorizing the public
the pervasive fear of nuclear
Devastation that haunted the Cold War
would manifest on screen as literal
monsters time and time again we Now
understand that radiation is more likely
to poison animal life than to create
Godzilla but what if that wasn't the
case
Baron a post-apocalyptic World building
project by Keegan Francis imagines an
alternate history where civilization
ended in nuclear conflict and mutated
animal life rapidly evolves to rule over
the irradiated waste left behind a retro
future that calls to mind the World
building of the Fallout series The
Project reveals a world where human
survivors must contend with biological
Horrors created by their own Folly so
for this entry into the archive we'll
travel across the wastes creating a
survival guide of sorts to the creatures
that roam this desolate world and if you
want to help support and build this
project there's a link to the artist
patreon down below now let's cross into
an alternate timeline and witness the
broken world of barren
we'll begin with the basics of mutant
biology in nature animals change over
time due to random genetic mutations
allowing certain members of a species to
better adapt to their environment and
pass on their genes with the irradiated
environments of Baron speeds up the rate
of these mutations considerably as a
result animals in this alternate
timeline now evolve to fill new niches
with alarming speed just a few
Generations after the World's End most
species of animals now look
unrecognizable compared to their pre-war
ancestors with Evolutions sent into
overdrive many familiar species will die
out in this new kingdom of fierce
competition
Beyond ambient Fallout the most extreme
mutations are brought on by an
irradiated strain of illness called
necrosis which subjects its host to even
more rapid evolutionary changes while
the disease often results in
advantageous mutations it simultaneously
reduces the host's lifespan making it
more of a curse than a blessing the
necrosis infection has become a
widespread issue in various regions
contaminating a significant percentage
of the post-war biosphere
the region we'll be exploring in this
video was once the United Kingdom yet
the green Landscapes of old have been
replaced by a grim Wasteland of Silent
Decay The People's Spirit remains
hopeful however resulting in the
Region's nickname The Unbroken Kingdom
for among the small pockets of survivors
hope is the last defense against the
dangers of the new world
in the new reality of The Unbroken
Kingdom Farms of old no longer exist
with most domesticated animals unable to
survive in the merciless new paradigm
new animals have assumed the role of
livestock in the settlements that have
risen From the Ashes the mighty bulwark
are a widespread species of farm animal
that are quite docile despite what their
horns and tusks might suggest these
mammals are related to pre-war cows
namely the Holstein Friesian in the
Highland cattle breeds with adults known
to weigh well over a ton bulb worker
classified as megafauna and have the
tenacity needed to endure the
unforgiving post-war reality taking a
closer look at the bulwarks hide we can
see that their thick leathery skin acts
as a kind of natural body armor while
they retain The Familiar pattern of
their bovine ancestors the bulwark's
protective hide is closer to that of an
old world rhino post-warf Farmers rear
bulwarks on the fertile fields around a
region called new Yorkshire making the
area one of the more prosperous in The
Unbroken Kingdom
yet bulwarks aren't the only new farm
animal found within the meager
settlements of the Kingdom The Uncanny
bone hens are a common sight in this new
world their cretaceous-esque features
make them well adapted to the harsh
environment with the bonehead spikes
helping them stay cool during heat waves
boneheads serve as a replacement for the
chickens of the old world and have
changed much from their tame
predecessors their beak is deceptively
strong designed to crush eggshells and
other discarded scraps for an easy
source of protein comparing a bone hens
feathers to the plumage of an old world
chicken it becomes clear that the bone
hands feathers are significantly more
fused and matted their makeup is almost
more akin to the hardened scales of a
reptile than the soft plumage of a bird
due to a shortage of food the surviving
government has released posters urging
civilians to rear bone hens as a source
of sustenance while eating a mutated
species like a bone hen is a viable
means of staying alive in Desperate
Times the long-term effects of consuming
such meals remain to be seen
just beyond the fences far more
dangerous life forms prowl the ruined
Countryside in some regions of The
Unbroken Kingdom hazard signs warn
travelers to stay clear of nearby Zager
nests mid-sized Predators the zaggers
are a well-known threat found all across
the former British Isles with
bone-crushing jaws in a poisonous Barb
on the end of their tail Sanders are the
bane of unwary Travelers who stray too
far from the path yet surprisingly these
deadly animals are the descendants of
the harmless pre-war Badger which grew
in size and ferocity to adapt to an
unforgiving World modern zaggers are
almost entirely hairless giving them a
wrinkled appearance closer analysis of
their glaborous skin indicates their
baldness is likely due to an amino acid
substitution in a hair growth Associated
protein an analogous pre-war mutation
had occurred in naked mole rats
resulting in their characteristic lack
of visible fur while unsettling in
appearance the mole rats were not
dangerous but in this world with
creatures like zaggers on the prowl
roaming the wild can be a serious
mistake
and more frightening things than zaggers
have evolved in The Unbroken Kingdom for
woodland animals aren't the only things
that have been mutated in the new world
some humans have been changed as well
characterized by their long frame Claws
and almost vampiric features these dark
reflections of humanity known as The
nucula Haunt the beer and wastes like
vengeful ghosts the nucula can vary in
many ways with most being frail and
sickly forcing them to become Ambush
Predators these slow nocula hide in
ruins of pre-war buildings feeding on
explorers who delve too deep for the
nucleus still possess their human
intelligence able to set traps to lure
and ensnare their unlucky victims
and in other parts of the unbroken
Kingdom rarer and more dangerous
variants of nucula have emerged fearsome
nucula are faster and bulkier than their
slow relatives unlike their smaller
counterparts fearsome nucula or roaming
Predators as opposed to their scavenger
cousins as a consequence of this
lifestyle the arms of fearsome nucula
have become larger and more heavily
muscled and their hands now end in
grasping Talons used to ensnare prey
their jaws and teeth have also evolved
and are now strong enough to break
through the hides of the tenacious
animals that roam the countryside
analysis suggests the Fearsome nucleus
extreme mutations come from the necrosis
disease while necrosis makes them apex
predators the illness also shortens
their lifespan meaning their numbers are
few
a more common life form can be found a
bit closer to the ground Dillo pigs are
animals that prove not all organisms in
this new age are quite so frightening a
pervasive species capable of reproducing
quickly these animals are often found on
the outskirts of settlements like
pre-war rodents dillu pigs proliferate
in large numbers and are quite Adept at
Scavenging for food unlike most pre-war
rodents however Dillo pigs have evolved
thick armor plating on their backs to
Shield against the predators of the
waste these hardened scales resemble the
protective leathery shell of Old World
armadillo species from which the Dillo
pigs get their nickname dillu pigs are
also known to create concealed nests
within pre-war ruins which they Retreat
into when threats arise and with
thousands of miles of abandoned piping
still present underground Dillo pigs
have plenty of room to make their
Burrows
thankfully the Dillo pig is one of the
few animals left in the world that could
be considered pet-like due to their
harmless nature and relatively cute
appearance
those who make their homes in the ruins
of urban areas must deal with other
types of animals gold wings are a
species of city-dwelling bat associated
with the growing region of New Yorkshire
despite their somewhat startling
appearance gold wings aren't aggressive
towards humans the descendants of
pre-war bats they feed primarily on
insects and other small organisms their
name comes from the golden hue of their
vibrant Wings which might serve as
camouflage against the ambient light of
cities most gold wings hunt by hanging
off lampposts and staying completely
still waiting for pests to run into the
open only to end up as an easy meal
because gold wings feed on
disease-carrying pests they've been
marked as an asset by the government of
The Unbroken Kingdom and are considered
a protected species as a result the
hunting of any gold wings within the
limits of new Yorkshire will earn
offenders a hefty fine
just beyond the outer limits of urban
areas scavengers lurk on the edges of
civilization the rot fowl or massive
birds that stand taller than a person
and feed on any carcasses that come
their way no matter how rotten or how
fresh often seen feasting upon remains
from local skirmishes they have earned
the nickname birds of war the descendant
of a pre-war bird of prey the rot fowl
had become larger and more terrestrial
than their ancestors having converged
Upon A towering body plan similar to The
Fearsome cassowaries of the old world to
match their unpleasant diet their beaks
had become sharp and hook-like get
rotfowl actually play a key role in
decomposition within their environment
like vultures the function they serve
within the food web might be on
glamorous yet it is fundamental to
various ecosystems for rotfowl don't
just affect the health of The Unbroken
Kingdom studies of their migratory
patterns indicate that rotfowl travel
across the North Sea once a year roaming
in large groups to other lands during
the height of their mating season
genetic mutations are responsible for
most of the fauna found Across The
Unbroken Kingdom yet the greatest
horrors of the wastes are in fact the
result of pre-war experiments conducted
by a company called biophageage a
clandestine organization with a long
history of ethical and moral violations
their Story begins long before the war
started originally formed as a
pharmaceutical Corporation the company
found its sales began to falter over the
decades everything changed however when
biophageage was taken over by one Dr
ellingham a successful businessman with
no background in biology and no
intention of engaging in ethical science
under his leadership biophage pivoted to
become a company on The Cutting Edge of
pre-war bioengineering the exact nature
of the early pre-war company experiments
is largely unknown and perhaps that is
for the best for what we do have on
record is bone chilling
not long before the outbreak of the war
biophage under the oversight of Dr
ellingham began experimenting with
medical Rejuvenation unit 151 would
become one of these many attempts
nicknamed ankle biters some of these
experiments could be considered
technically successful as the ankle
biters were able to regrow lost limbs as
intended yet the results were life forms
that could no longer be considered human
still biophage might have increased the
scale of these experiments were it not
for the violent claps of pre-war Society
yet not all experiments were destroyed
during the war some creations of
biophage escaped into the barren waste
and have been able to carve out a niche
in the brutal new natural hierarchy
today perhaps no life form in The
Unbroken kingdom is more dangerous than
the seldom scene biophageage experiment
that stalks the open Plains vespores are
ruthless bioweapons capable of Horrors
far beyond any naturally evolved form of
life while the original intention behind
their creation remains unknown the
results of the experiment are visible to
all
vespore's hunt with a stinger-like
appendage capable of spearing
fast-moving prey once an animal has been
speared the vespore then prepares to
digest The Unlucky creature the internal
anatomy of a vespore allows them to
digest prey directly through their
abdomen making them extremely efficient
as they are able to Feast while on the
move the terrifying behavior of the
vespor coupled with its elusive Nature
has caused it to take on an almost
mythical status in the minds of the
survivors for not many CIA vespor and
live to tell the tale
aside from terrifying monsters there is
a quiet sadness that the world of Baron
evokes it's hard not to read through the
project and feel a certain Melancholy
for all that has been lost bustling
towns healthy forests clean rivers much
of the world as it existed before the
apocalypse has changed utterly and might
never return to normal yet the people of
this alternate timeline have adapted to
the changes much like the strange fauna
that now roamed the Wilderness The
Unbroken Kingdom might be an unfamiliar
landscape but so long as it's possible
to continue to endure it will never be a
broken one there's much more to the
baron project than I was able to cover
in this video if you want to see more of
the world of Baron you can support
Keegan Francis on his patreon down below
to access bonus content and help the
project continue
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video